I think femininity can truly flourish in
an environment whereby she's safe and
safety is masculinity it's masculine
energy it's um showing her that
everything's gonna be okay you know
solving problems for her that is how
femininity can truly flourish and so
when a man can be and that's powerful
and they won't clip out they won't clip
that up being a mother is just as
important as being a CEO shout out to
Elon Musk was saying that that's a great
point being a mom being a woman is just
as important but you've been deluded to
think that men are better in terms of
business and everything it's equal and
I've made that mistake saying that
before too when I say I'm better I mean
I'm better at doing what I do I'm better
at pursuing but the role of a woman is
just as important as the role of a man
it's not worse it's not oppressive women
are strong in their own way and we need
to encourage that we need to stop
telling women that to be strong they
need to be men when you start telling
women that to be powerful and to be
themselves be the strongest woman you
can be that's